se extiende La tregua en Sudán el
ejército sudanés anunció a través de un
comunicado que prolongaría por otras 72
horas la duración del armisticio que
expiró a la medianoche de este jueves la
decisión de la facción liderada por
abdelfata alburham viene después de la
propuesta realizada por dos grupos
compuestos por enviados diplomáticos de
Estados Unidos Reino Unido Arabia
Saudita Noruega y la organización
regional africana y gab burjan dio las
gracias a lijath y expresó su aprobación
inicial al respecto
los esfuerzos internacionales por lograr
extender el cese al fuego tienen el
objetivo de proteger los corredores
humanitarios y facilitar las
extracciones de civiles desde jartum en
una declaración conjunta el secretario
de estado estadounidense Anthony
blinquen y el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
subrayaron los esfuerzos conjuntos de la
comunidad internacional para abordar el
conflicto
estamos colaborando estrechamente para
hacer frente a la crisis de Sudán con la
esperanza de lograr un alto al fuego más
duradero
el cese las hostilidades y ayudar a
Sudán a retomar el camino hacia un
gobierno civil
al tiempo que nos enfrentamos a una
situación humanitaria cada vez más
difícil
el grupo paramilitar fa reaccionó al
comunicado del ejército sudanés
positivamente acordando armisticio por
las 72 horas anunciadas en el comunicado
inicial del ejército la última tregua
temporal fue acordada el 24 de abril
aunque no fue respetada del todo y los
enfrentamientos continuaron la Casa
Blanca se ha declarada preocupada por
las constantes violaciones del cese al
fuego y urge a los ciudadanos salir de
Sudán